석유를 팔았습니다. 그런데 돈을 못 받았습니다.
그것도 한두 달이 아니라 몇 년 동안 말이죠.
더 황당한 건 그 돈이 아예 사라진 것도 아니라는 점입니다.
분명 한국은행들에 묶여있는데
막상 돌려주려 하니까 70억 달러 정도 되던 돈이
갑자기 60억 달러가 돼 있었습니다.
이란 입장에서는 당연히 열받을 만한 일입니다.
그런데 여기서 진짜 흥미로운 건 따로 있습니다.
이 돈을 묶어버린 건 미국인데
왜 이란은 한국에 유독 더 감정이 안 좋을까요?
왜 미국보다 한국을 더 직접적인 문제의 당사자처럼 대할까요?
이번 영상에서 다룰 이야기는 바로 그 부분입니다.
이건 단순히 외교 갈등이 아닙니다.
석유대금, 미국의 제재, 한국은행들, 가짜 서류 사건, 횡령, 환율 손실,
그리고 카타르의 다시 묶인 60억 달러까지 하나씩 따라가다 보면
왜 이란이 한국을 그냥 스쳐 지나가는 나라로 보지 않는지
그 이유가 꽤 선명하게 드러납니다.
이 이야기의 출발점은 한국이 이란의 돈을 훔쳤느냐가 아닙니다.
출발점은 어느 순간 이란 돈이 한국 금융권 안에 묶이기 시작했다는 데 있습니다.
당시 한국은 이란산 원유를 적지 않게 수입하고 있었습니다.
그런데 미국이 이란 제재를 강화하면서
이 돈을 예전처럼 자유롭게 달러로 주고받는 길이 막히기 시작합니다.
그래서 만들어진 구조가 원화결제 계정이었습니다.
이란이 한국의 석유를 팔면 그 대금이 한국의 은행 계좌에 쌓입니다.
하지만 이란은 그 돈을 마음대로 달러로 바꾸거나
자유롭게 꺼내 쓸 수는 없었습니다.
여기까지만 들으면 그냥 불편한 거래구조 정도로 보일 수 있습니다.
그런데 진짜 문제는 이 돈을 묶어둔 방식이 생각보다 훨씬 허술했다는 점입니다.
2011년에 미국 수사당국이 주목한 사건이 터집니다.
겉으로 보기에는 별거 아닌 거래처럼 보였습니다.
두바이 대리석 같은 건축자재를 이란에 수출하고
그 대금을 받는 정상적인 무역처럼 보였죠.
그런데 나중에 드러난 건 이 서류들이 대부분 위조였다는 점입니다.
가짜 계약서.
가짜 송장.
가짜 선적 서류를 이용해서 한국에 묶여있던 이란 자금을
합법 무역 대금처럼 보이게 만든 뒤 빼낸 겁니다.
이 사건 이후 미국과 뉴욕 금융당국의 시선은 자연스럽게 한국은행들로 향합니다.
핵심은 단순했습니다.
이란 관련 자금이 이렇게까지 움직였다는 건
그 돈을 걸러내고 막아야 할 한국은행들의 내부 통제가
그만큼 허술했다는 뜻으로 보였기 때문입니다.
실제로 이 사건 이후 한국은행들은 줄줄이 조사 대상이 오르게 됩니다.
농협은 자금 세탁을 막는 내부 시스템이
제대로 갖춰져 있지 않다는 이유로 벌금을 맞았고
기업은행은 더 큰 규모의 문제로 이어졌었죠.
결국 미국이 내린 판단은 분명했습니다.
한국은행들은 이란 돈을 관리하는 창구였지만
그 역할을 맡기기에는 너무 허술해 보였다는 겁니다.
여기서 시청자 입장에서는 이런 질문이 생길 수 있습니다.
그래도 결국 제재를 건 건 미국인데
왜 한국에게 유독 예민하냐는 질문이 생길 수 있죠.
그 질문에 대한 답이 본격적으로 드러난 건 2018년 이후입니다.
트럼프가 이란 핵 합의에서 빠져나오고
대이란 제재를 다시 강하게 복원하면서
한국 금융권에 쌓여 있던 이란 자금은 사실상 꼼짝 못하게 됩니다.
이란 입장에서는 상황이 아주 단순했습니다.
석유는 이미 팔았습니다.
돈도 분명히 존재합니다.
그런데 그 돈을 가져갈 수가 없습니다.
그리고 그 돈이 실제로 묶여 있던 곳이
바로 한국의 은행 계좌였던 겁니다.
바로 여기서부터 한국은 이란에게
괜히 더 불편한 나라가 되기 시작합니다.
미국은 멀리서 규칙을 만든 나라일 수는 있습니다.
하지만 한국은 다르죠.
이란 눈에는 자기 돈을 손에 쥐고
있으면서도 돌려주지 않는 나라처럼 보일 수밖에 없습니다.
원인을 만든 건 미국이었지만
매일 눈 앞에서 내 돈을 안 주는 나라는 한국이었던 셈입니다.
그런데 문제는 여기서 끝나지 않습니다.
시간이 한참 지난 뒤에
한국에 대한 이란의 불신을 더 키운 사건이 또 터집니다.
바로 대우 일렉트로닉스 인수 무산과 얽힌 돈의 문제였습니다.
2010년에 이란 엔텍합 측은 대우 일렉 인수를 추진하면서
약 578억 원의 계약금을 냈습니다.
하지만 인수는 최종적으로 무산됐고
이후 이란 측은 이 돈을 돌려달라며 분쟁에 들어갑니다.
이란은 긴 분쟁 끝에 결국 돈을 돌려받을 길이 열리는 듯했습니다.
그러나 막상 돈을 보려고 확인해 보니
그 자리에 있어야 할 돈이 크게 비어 있었던 겁니다.
우리 은행 직원이 그 자금을 장기간에 걸쳐 빼돌린 사실이 드러난 거죠.
이란 입장에서 보면 얼탱이가 없는 일이겠죠.
내 돈이 묶여 있는 것도 일단 화가 나는데
그 돈을 관리하는 쪽에서 이런 사고까지 터진 겁니다.
이쯤 되면 불만이 단순히 제재 때문만은 아니게 됩니다.
이제는 한국 금융권 전체에 대한 불신으로 바뀌게 되죠.
돈을 늦게 주는 나라, 돈을 자유롭게 못 쓰게 하는 나라,
심지어 그 돈을 관리하는 방식도 허술한 나라라는 인식이 쌓이기 시작하는 겁니다.
그리고 여기서 이란 입장에서 가장 억울하게 느낄 수 있는 장면이 나옵니다.
바로 70억 달러가 실제 이전 단계에서 60억 달러가 된 겁니다.
돈이 줄어든 이유는 간단합니다.
이 돈은 처음부터 달러로 보관된 게 아니라
한국 안에 원화 기반 계정에 오래 머물러 있었습니다.
한국의 환전과 이전은 훨씬 뒤늦게 이뤄졌죠.
그 사이 원화 가치가 떨어지면서 달러 기준으로 계산한 금액도 줄어든 겁니다.
그러니 이란 입장에서는 화가 날 수밖에 없습니다.
이건 제재의 문제가 아니라 내 돈이 몇 년 동안 묶여있었고
막상 돌려받을 때는 액수까지 줄어들어 있다?
이거 열의 안 받으면 이상한 거죠.
그런데 더 아이러니한 장면은 그 다음에 나옵니다.
2023년 미국과 이란의 수감자 교환이 진행되면서
한국에 묶여있던 이자금은 드디어 카타르로 옮겨집니다.
겉으로 보면 오랫동안 막혀있던 돈이 이제야 풀리는 것처럼 보였습니다.
하지만 실제로는 그렇지 않았습니다.
이 돈은 이란이 마음대로 꺼내 쓸 수 있는 현금이 아니었습니다.
식품, 의약품, 의료기기처럼 인도적 목적에만 쓸 수 있는 제한된 자금이었죠.
즉 한국을 빠져나가기는 했지만 이란이 완전히 되찾은 돈은 아니었던 겁니다.
그런데 바로 다음 달 10월 7일 하마스의 이스라엘 기습이 벌어지면서 상황은 다시 얼어붙습니다.
카타르로 옮겨졌던 60억 달러도 사실상 다시 묶이게 되죠.
이 장면이 중요한 이유는 분명합니다.
이란 입장에서는 이 돈이 한국에 있을 때도 자유롭지 않았고
카타르로 간 뒤에도 자유롭지 않았기 때문입니다.
그런데도 이 긴 이야기에서 가장 오래 남은 이름은 결국 한국입니다.
실제로 자기 돈을 가장 오랫동안 가지고 있었던 국가가 한국이기 때문입니다.
이제 왜 이란이 한국에게 유독 감정이 안 좋은지 이해가 되시나요?
첫 번째, 미국이 제재를 했어도 이란이 실제로 돈이 묶인 걸 겪은 상대는
한국이기 때문입니다.
한국이 제재를 했어도 이란이 실제로 돈이 묶인 걸 겪은 상대는
두 번째, 석유를 팔고도 돈을 오랫동안 가져가지 못한 기억이
한국의 은행 계좌와 연결돼 있습니다.
세 번째, 그 과정에서 가짜 서류 사건, 미국의 은행 제재,
우리은행 횡령 사건까지 이어지면서 신뢰가 크게 흔들렸습니다.
마지막으로 네 번째, 몇 년을 기다린 끝에 돈을 돌려받으려 했더니
원화의 가치가 하락해서 액수마저 줄어들었습니다.
결국 문제를 만든 쪽은 미국이었지만
이란이 그 대가를 가장 직접적으로 마주한 상태는
한국이었습니다.
멀리서 규칙을 만든 나라보다 내 돈을 실제로 가지고 있는 나라가
더 기억에 남는 법이죠.
이란과 한국 사이의 갈등은 바로 그 감정이 어떻게 쌓였는지를
보여주는 사례에 가깝습니다.
석유대금은 묶였고 환율은 그 돈의 체감 가치를 깎아냈고
제재는 감정의 기억으로 남았습니다.
결국 이란이 한국을 기억하는 이유는 외교 때문만이 아니라
자기 돈이 한국에서 가장 오래 멈춰 있었기 때문입니다.
영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.